the decrease in price never equates to
the corresponding increase
in sales i'll give you one hard learned
example that i had
my employees two years ago bitched and
moaned about how they thought
we were too expensive soul crushing
right because they were like our churn
is 15 month over month
right it's terrible it's it's it's yeah
heartbreaking and we had been there for
like a year
they're like i think we got to lower our
price so we said we're going to go from
800 a week to 600 a week
that was going to be our price drop we
made this big announcement
right big announcement super excited not
only that we're going to give a discount
and add coaching services on top so
we're going to give more for less
just crazy over delivery first off
i got complaints from clients because
they were upset that they had paid more
number two i cut my profit by 400
dollars a month and my churn remained
the same
wow so that series of employees lost me
five
million dollars
wow and you do not have to learn that
lesson